papa les peines ont été prononcées je
suis condamnée à mort ne dis rien à
maman voici les derniers mots cas
adressez-moi à Mehdi Karami 22 ans à son
père quelques jours avant d'être pendu
le 7 janvier dernier par le régime
islamique iranien Mohamed Mehdi et un
autre iranien ça y est de Mohamed
Hosseini 39 ans était incarcéré depuis
fin novembre accusé du meurtre d'un
paramilitaire chargé de la sécurité en
marge d'une manifestation anti régime à
30 km de Téhéran la capitale les parents
mords d'inquiétude avaient tenté de
mobiliser les réseaux sociaux dans une
vidéo je demande avec tout mon respect
aux responsables judiciaires d'épargner
mon fils de la peine de mort supplié le
père en vain les dernières paroles de
Carami à son père sont désormais
devenues virales en Iran les images du
père de Karami ivres de chagrin pleurant
sur la tombe de son fils recouverte de
fleurs ont également ému au-delà des
frontières il s'agit de la quatrième
exécution par pendaison depuis le début
des manifestations en Iran déclenchées
par la mort de l'iranienne kurde Marsa
Amini en septembre accusé d'avoir mal
porté son voile